this one must be reviewed why because i
love dogs
if you all don't remember gypsy in
danger named after exactly what you
think you're so going on the thumbnail
the league of super pets is pretty much
a justice league movie that revolves
around crypto superman's dog and a bunch
of super powered animals there's this
nefarious little sinister villainous
animal he gets this big plot going
superman and the justice league they've
all been captured so you know it's up to
the pets it's up to the animals it's up
to the better part of all of us because
we all know the math that is the math
yeah cat people i love cats too but
undeniably cats will plot your death if
not the very lazy ones will wait for you
to die hope for you to die so they can
eat your body but dogs
no one will love you as much as your
dogs now the rock i know his name is
dwayne johnson that's what the posters
say i'm i'm never gonna he's the rock
forever point is the rock voices crypto
superman's dog kevin hart voices this
other dog it's pretty much they have the
batman superman canine dynamic going on
and i mean
this movie's no minions rise have grew
never thought i'd say that in a sentence
i mean the movie does have some charm
that definitely works does have some
humor that does work and that's where
the movie to its core is at its best
it's where its strength lies it's when
it's tugging at those heartstrings
playing up that bond that mystical bond
between human and dog
just funny because superman's kryptonian
i'll figure that out later you know what
i mean there were a couple moments i was
like man this is really hidden
dog people am i right and some of the
humor and i do stress some of the humor
did land with me but when it was trying
too hard or otherwise breaking the
fourth wall with the tumor just it fell
flat and i don't feel like i'm alone in
that there were a lot of people in this
auditorium it was just radio silent then
we would all laugh at the same thing but
it was it was few and far between which
is a bummer because there were a lot of
kids a lot of families in this
auditorium and usually that's a good
metric for who's having a good time
there's a part of me that was like this
is more geared towards kids but the kids
didn't seem to care either so there's
that hands down funniest thing in the
movie is batman more specifically who
voices batman did not pick it up from
the trailer that better be a licensed
toy or i will freak out for people like
me who didn't catch it let me help you
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out right he's incredible i don't
think he has more than 10 or 20 lines in
the entire movie but he's incredible
every line is comedy gold he crushed it
for a lot of the rest of the movie it
was a 99 cent justice league adventure
kevin hart and the rock i thought were
great we've seen them have great
chemistry great dynamic on screen before
i thought they were great in here too
granted i feel like
they were the ones carrying the entire
movie
playing keanu is batman there is that
but in the world where the justice
league and the characters of the justice
league are largely not in the film it is
on dwayne johnson and kevin hart i
thought this movie started off strong
with superman and his dog and they're
palling around i was like i connect and
ended stronger i thought the last 10 or
15 minutes of the movie was actually
really good it was exciting it played up
its premise better it wasn't trying to
be too funny though the end was kind of
a three-phase boss fight and that kind
of started to get boring but in the end
the kids in the auditorium didn't seem
any more interested than i was in this
movie some chuckles here and they're
absolutely tugging at the heartstrings
you bet but it seems like a half-baked
if not half-assed justice league premise
that they just passed off to the pets
and in the end even if your kids would
love it you're gonna need a little more
of those human dog treats yeah no it's a
party all right so league of super pets
are you looking forward to it are you
gonna take your kids remember that
episode of smallville with crypto
we all do whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
all right gypsy
what's your favorite movie
the exorcist
that's unexpected oh you hate cameras so
much
you do have a dome head
and that makes you mighty
it's like just throw the kong
into the dome of triumph